first they kicked this whole thing off
and this was this was actually a big
shocker to me they
they kicked us off by talking about
corporal alvin york
united states army right so
i expected this to be all marines but
the marine corps is awesome
and they said hey these are awesome
examples of where a squad leader made a
difference
and we're going to use them
france 1918
the muse argonne offensive
was the last important battle of the
first world war on the night of 25
september 1918 over one million american
soldiers moved up to relieve the french
forces on the front lines
the american advance that ensued swept
easily through the first two lines of
german trenches
and then progress slowed facing stiff
resistance
the reserve division was called up
corporal alvin york served as an
infantry man in the 82nd division
york's company started across a valley
at six in the morning as they began to
move the company came
under heavy fire from behind a hill
enemy machine guns
mowed down the first wave of advancing
americans
no one knew where the deadly fire was
coming from so
york's platoon sergeant decided to take
the platoon on a mission to find it
the platoon found a gap in the enemy
lines and circled to the rear
where they thought the machine guns
might be the group of americans
stumbled across two german
litter-bearers whom
they followed back to the headquarters
of the machine gun battalion
the americans walked right into the
german machine gun command post
opened fire and the germans immediately
surrendered
upon hearing the fire behind them the
germans
that were dug in near the command post
swung their weapons around and began
firing at the americans
caught in the open in a hail of
automatic fire the americans
instantly took casualties corporal
york took aim at the nearest machine gun
about 25 yards away
and killed the man behind the gun he
continued to fire
each german who popped his head out of a
foxhole
after watching his troops being
massacred by this lone
sharpshooter the german major in command
yelled
to york if you'll stop shooting
i'll make them surrender
work on your marksmanship people work on
your marksmanship
within minutes the remaining american
troops had captured
90 german prisoners but they were behind
enemy lines
corporal york took charge and quickly
organized his platoon
he decided to move back towards friendly
positions straight through the german
lines
york ordered the german prisoners to
carry back the american wounded
every time the group came upon a german
position
york told the captured german major
to order the troops to surrender
the well-disciplined german soldiers
never questioned the order
and by the time york's small band
reached friendly lines
they had acquired 132 german prisoners
in their wake york's platoon left 35
deserted
german machine gun positions and a
significant gap in the german defenses
this gap which york had created was a
vital element to the success of the
division's advance
this advance gave momentum to the
american forces and contributed to the
success
of the offensive
phenomenal here's the lessons
corporal york was quick to exploit the
opportunity which had been created
he realized that his actions would
affect the outcome of the battalion's
advance and made decisions which
supported
his commander's intent his strong
situational awareness
guided him in taking action which had
decisive results
you know when you think even when i
think when i think of world war
one soldiers you i definitely envision
someone that's much more obedient than
what we have in the modern all-volunteer
military today
right you've got someone that's hey i
mean i would say the whole world was
more
obedient right you had a much more
stringent class structure
in america you had the much further
separation between the officers and the
enlisted
and so so for this kid
to be like oh i got this
it's it's incredible it's incredible to
show that kind of initiative and i think
the fact that it was
in world war one is even more incredible
think about what would happen if he was
just standing around waiting to be told
what to do in that situation though
which is what
so many leaders we work with think is
the right call like
you should just wait to be told what to
do and then do you know carry on orders
without question
and uh and he would just be standing
there waiting to be told to do and and
they would fail and maybe the whole
offensive fails
as a result instead of someone who
actually understands the why
understands the commander's intent and
the purpose behind what what they're
trying to do
and can take the initiative to go make
things happen yeah you know what
uh i often say and i wrote about
i don't want yes men right i don't wanna
know someone that's just like yep hey
yeah sounds good jocko
sounds great you know you want someone
that's gonna push back and like hey i
don't agree with that wait what about
this
you take that one step further it's like
i want someone that's just gonna
figure out what to do and go freaking
execute it right that's what we want
that's what we're trying that's what we
want that's what we're trying to grow
this we're trying to
develop in our supported leadership is
that they are gonna
look even look beyond even look beyond
what i can see
and say oh i bet if i did this it would
be a good move
and maybe they're batting 80 percent i'm
good with that
i'd rather have somebody batting 80 on
80 good moves that took initiative and
made things happen and
20 percent of the time i got to go oh
hey hold what you got man don't go over
there yet
much rather have that initiative
but that's something you've you've
helped me with as well though with
because i think it's a hard thing for a
lot of leaders to accept it's like well
you know we got to come up with the
right solution we don't want to make
mistakes and we want to
move forward and when you're you're like
listen
80 solutions that go 80 solutions to go
where if we're never going to have a
perfect plan so let's
let's get the plan as close you know in
in
a good direction and then execute and
execute and execute and have the
initiative be default aggressive
uh i think i think that's i know it can
stifle me uh and i've struggled with
that
and i'm i'm not executing because i'm
trying to get it to the 97
solution like listen 80 solutions start
moving things forward execute
and i think that's very empowering to
think about that you don't have to have
the perfect plan
yeah you gotta just go yeah very
liberating
to be like oh yeah i don't care about
that hey
we might not be oh yeah i don't care you
know we well what if
you don't care about that dude that hill
over there
yeah get there well do you want me to
have a logistics no i don't care about
that
well do you want me to do it in the
daytime i don't care
well do you want no i don't care once
you get that hill
okay but let's do it the the point i'm
making here though is
is you know even whether it's echelon
front or working together and tasking a
bruiser
in you know there can be something like
in my mind where i'm like hey you know
taco's really good at this and i i got
to make sure that jocko under you know
has
like this is the right plan and it's
going to meet every single thing that
you know he wants to do so
you start putting these self-imposed
restrictions instead of like
when you're like hey man 80 solutions go
bro let's execute
and that that's it's super liberating to
think about it that way
and you realize like hey what i thought
you know i've got to get this thing
perfect so you know jack was like yeah
that's good
i actually don't and i'm actually i'm
actually failing if i'm not executing
and i'm
i'm sitting here trying to come up with
a perfect plan yeah there's uh some
report you were trying to get and
you were like hey you know i haven't
gotten you this report because i can't
quite figure out this little detail at
the end to make sure that it's 100
and i just i i i'm just not getting it
to you because i don't want it to be
inaccurate
and i don't want to have you like pissed
and i was like
bro actually i remember exactly i said
have i ever sweated you for the details
on
anything in the past 15 years and it was
funny you
you kind of you you tilted your head a
little bit and you went
nope and i was like why do you think i
would start sweating these little like
literally in meaningless meaningless
uh details and you're like roger i'm an
idiot cool got it
so no factor and that's a that that is a
great example though because here i am
stewing about trying to put together a
multi-page report and you're like hey
bro just send me a
just just say hey i don't have the i
don't have all the information yet
here's what i think we're doing
here's kind of the general you know
direction we should go and as soon as
you said that i was like
just another reminder uh that it's
self-imposed restrictions and it's
it's really uh it can cause all kinds of
problems so yeah and
and obviously that means i'm doing a bad
job of
you know telling you what the parameters
are
of success you know if i'm like hey can
you tell me what these numbers are
you're like cool yeah but it's going to
take me three weeks to dive into all
these details
if i was like hey and i you know i was
like hey dude i just need a little like
ballpark
where are we at okay got it because i
can give you that in 13 minutes
but you know it's the it goes back to
some of that
implied implied commander's intent right
because the implied commander's intent
is that
when i ask for something i need that
thing right
hey you know when jacqueline asks for
something because he doesn't ask for
much when he asks for something he must
want that thing
really exact the implied intent is that
i want the implied intent with me is
basically i want perfection
right that's that's that's a complete
implied intent and for some reason
echo's never really picked up on that
platform no that's actually not true
if i think about it like the the way
there's been some things where i've seen
i found out after the fact what you did
to reach a level of
as close as a human can get to
perfection on something where i've been
like
i didn't expect him to do all that but
he did it so
that implied level of perfection
just from my own stupid personality is
like enough to make someone say
i i better get this right before you
know we go forward
and that sucks and and and i talked
about it at gettysburg
i was like you've got to think about
what your implied
what your implied commander's intent is
and if especially if you're going to ask
them to do something that's outside that
normal
implied commander's intent and you know
we talked about it with with
general lee and some of his some of his
subordinate leaders that
hey general lee was about kicking ass so
we're moving here what's general legal
want me to do he's going to want me to
kick ass
go forward but he said hey you know
don't go forward right now
but they get that word they're like yeah
but it's generally i'm gonna go get some
and they messed things up so you got to
pay attention to that
implied commander's intent that just
your personality has
your own personality has a has a culture
to it
and you got to pay attention scary
that was a uh that was some rare praise
for echo charles said we gotta note that
down
take a well-deserved well-deserved
obviously thanks both of you guys
yeah yeah i mean i'm thinking like the
first time we ever went to
like travel to do the podcast and you
had like a
and i expected i was like i had my
fingers crossed my toes crossed
my ears crossed hoping that you know all
this
quote all this equipment showed up and
we'd be able to you know we have
some guests come in and it's going to be
there the time is valuable and all this
stuff and i'm like thinking i hope this
and yeah you had it all you know in the
pelican case
yep everything was there i was like
right
away squared away which is not you know
maybe what everyone expects maybe some
people have a different implied
scenario